skill set or thing that I've learned in
business that had pretty much shocked me
I really only learned this in last year
but looking back at it people have told
me this forever which is there's a
massive difference a massive gap in
skills and a lot of people cross it but
there's the gap exists of starting and
managing so when you start businesses a
lot of people think of Mark Zuckerberg
and they're like this college kid
started this thing he was 20 when he
started it now he's only 30 or he could
be 25 still and he manages 10,000
employees he hired the the best people
in the world from Princeton and Stanford
and Harvard and he stole people from
Amazon the brightest minds on earth and
you think yeah that's just how it goes
well managing those people and the
business it's incredibly challenging and
oftentimes the people who are creative
and crazy enough to start companies a
lot of times the skill sets they needed
to start it are not only different but
oftentimes opposite of what it takes to
run when you start something you could
look at a lot of spreadsheets and you
could kind of like guess your way there
but a lot of times not all the time but
a lot of times starting something it's
completely irrational on paper things
may or may not work and you just got to
be creative in you got to do you
got to move fast and you're not gonna
have meetings you're not gonna talk to
people about stuff you're just gonna
move quickly you're gonna execute you're
gonna do it and it's a very creative
process it's almost like creating a
piece of art like maybe there's some
equation that says like the perfect
rectangle looks this way but every but a
lot of times there's just Picasso who
just says it this is interesting to
me I'm doing this and sometimes it works
that's kind of what's starting up
businesses but managing a business is a
lot different and so at our company I
did a pretty good job of getting us to
about a million a month in sales but
towards the ends of that I was breaking
I was doing horrible I was not good at
managing it and I was very unhappy and
so we hired one of my first hires was
this guy named Adam who I want to
I school with and he's now president of
our company and he runs a lot of the
day-to-day stuff so I kind of I kind of
I'm like he's like Sam sandwiched in the
middle whereas I'm really good at
thinking of these really high level
ideas and I'm also really good at going
in at the very bottom and just being an
individual contributor and creating
interesting things I'm not always great
at managing the day-to-day of what's
going on it's I bet I could get good at
it but it just really doesn't interest
me and that was really hard to learn and
I struggled with this for years I like I
said I hired a CEO coach I had we have a
handful of really great angel investors
and I kind of talked to them I'm like I
don't know what to do here and it wasn't
until I realized that Adam is one of the
best at this he loves us he's the type
of guy who was the captain the football
team the President of Student Council he
loves leading people and it kind of hit
me I'm like man the way that I sometimes
don't understand why people are
unwilling to start something or how on
earth they're afraid of starting I am
kind of like that on the other end with
managing there's people who it whether
it comes naturally to them or they've
just worked on this skill set they're
really good at it and so in a way I was
wearing this backpack that was full of
weight and I hated carrying it on my
shoulders I just took out some of the
weight and I put it in Adams bag and he
loves carrying it and so through this
process ice mentioned earlier we have
hustle con speakers through this process
I actually talked to a lot of people at
our conferences and that was one of the
major things that I used to ask people
which is if you have a right-hand man or
a right-hand woman do you have someone
leading the day-to-day because I'm
struggling with that how do you do that
and there was typically two answers
which was yeah I don't like it it's
really hard and I could sense that these
people I'm talking I mean I don't want
to I don't want to call anyone out but
go and just Google like hustle con
speakers or something look at all the
people who we've had at our events and
those these are this is the type of
person or those are the people who told
me this which was they would say like I
am horrible at managing this or often
they would have liked one of their
assistants or like a keeper or like a
handler like with them
and I would be like hey what's this
person like as a manager and the answers
were pretty consistently pretty bad this
person's not good and so the the first
answer was I'm not good at it I'm really
struggling with it and a lot of times
those people would say I wish I had
someone who I could replace myself a CEO
I I would hear that all the time and you
I was shocked by it and the second
answer that I got was yeah I hired a
really good C oo or really good
president and this is my right-hand
woman or right-hand man and they run a
lot of the day-to-day and it allows me
to focus on what I do best and the
people who said number two were way
happier and oftentimes I think a lot
more successful now there are these rare
occasions where the person who started
is just they're there they're also a
great CEO or a great people manager that
that definitely happens but often it is
not the case I'm looking at a photo of
Ted Turner Ted Turner's one of my heroes
he was pretty notoriously a bad manager
he was a great leader people wanted to
follow him in battle but what he would
do is he would come up with these great
ideas so Ted Turner came up with the
idea of seeing in and he launched it but
before that he had other businesses and
when he came up to CNN a lot of people
think Ted Turner you're the guy started
seeing in well yeah he is but he also
there's another guy named Reese and
Reese was the guy leading the day-to-day
Ted would came up with the idea and then
he went away for three months and did a
sailing competition so having these
right hand people are is very important
and a lot of times I feel like I'm the
right hand person at this point but I
think that it's really important to
understand the difference between
starting and managing I mean for a long
time for a long time it was normal that
they would calm gray hairs it was normal
to get a gray haired leader to come in
for a startup so these young people
would come up with this idea for this
great tech company and then this
investor would say all right let's go
guys CEO and that is not popular right
now but I think it should be I think
it's actually quite effective maybe not
CEO but you definitely need this team of
experienced people and and so the reason
why I brought this up is it's a it's
something that most
people I found struggle with but there's
not a lot of resources out there not a
lot of people talking about it and so I
think it's really important to learn
this ultimately I'm the skills that
comes out to delegating and there's four
resources that I'll have that I've liked
the first one I don't like the name of
the book but it's very helpful it's by a
guy named Fela
Felix Dennis Felix Dennis he was this
he's dead now he died a few years ago
maybe ten years ago he was he's kind of
like Richard Branson but more vulgar he
was a British entrepreneur he started
Denis publishing which launched Maxim
magazine which launched a ton of great
tiles it's still like a 200 million
dollar year business he also launched
micro warehouse which basically before
Amazon was around it was like Amazon for
software and it was a huge multi-billion
dollar publicly-traded company so very
successful entrepreneur close to a
billionaire and so this is why I don't
mind his book being titled so horribly
it's called how to get rich and the
reason why I don't mind is because he
was really successful he wasn't this
like get-rich-quick guy and in that book
he does a great job of talking about
delegating and that book I use it as a
reference book I read all the time about
how to work with people that that's
might go to the second one is I like the
one minute manager just google it you'll
find it it's a great book on managing
the third thing is is the five
dysfunctions of a team and so it's a
great book that looks at what successful
teams and people look like and what they
don't look like more importantly and so
you in order to oftentimes the best way
to be good at something is you find out
the bad ways of doing it and you just
don't do that and the fourth thing is
one of my investors is this guy named
Tucker max Tucker max if you're a man
and you're between the ages of probably
28 and 40 you probably know who Tucker
max is he was famous because you know
this blog called I hope they serve beer
in hell and it was very controversial it
was basically about his frat days and he
was just this wild partier and drinker
so he has a really controversial opinion
but after he's in his 40s now so he's no
longer a kid but he's really thoughtful
at this point he's kind of turned his
image around and he has a great blog
where he a talked about firing himself
and replacing himself as CEO and he
it's maybe like a 12-part blog it's
really good I would highly recommend
everyone reading him and he's one of my
investors and he's kind of an a mentor
to me you know he him and I are kind of
similar and that we try to be macho and
or at least we started that way of
wanting to be macho and show no weakness
but he's actually done a really good job
of being introspective and talking about
his feelings a lot and he's done really
good about talking about managing people
he Tucker also has this great book on
how to create or this great document on
how to manage a company or like create a
culture and nuclear Google Tucker Mac
sculpture document and you'll see it
it's free
[Music]
you